if some of those great people that were
in that club that night had guns
strapped to their waist or strapped to
their ankle the bad guys don't know
which one of us are carrying so we all
become safer for every concealed carry
permit holder pop up once you're really
afraid and think that the gun is your
salvation and the idea of having it
taken away from you is scary yeah a shot
in the head so I went like in here out
here went three right there so you know
brings back some weird memories you know
it really does like it's kind of just
weird being back I'm glad I'm going to
be honest this is the parking lot in San
Francisco where four years ago 25 year
old Ben Pesa was shot in the head loot
advances towards his girlfriend outside
of a Halloween party sparked a
confrontation that nearly turned deadly
and you were right around here yeah I
was like probably right here well guy
walked past her and kind of like brushes
her a little bit he grabbed her breasts
I'm like you say you're sorry or
apologize he's like you know I got a gun
fro he got his gun in the trunk of his
car I thought it was a fake gun you know
I did because it went along with his
costume he was wearing fatigues and he
pulls out a cock she started shooting
one bullet went straight through my head
that was pretty much the hit
after being in a medically-induced coma
for nearly a month has to woke up in the
hospital with an artificial skull he was
lucky to be alive
Benjamin was transferred to UC San
Francisco yesterday then today another
giant step literally Hey sure the young
man took his first step even after being
shot in the head
HESA like many Americans still believes
that people have a right to carry a gun
the ability to legally carry guns in
public is increasingly becoming the norm
over the last three decades all 50
states have passed laws allowing
citizens to carry concealed weapons some
states make it more complicated to
obtain a permit while others have few
restrictions in place many of the states
that fought their first innovation of
allowing citizens to apply for a permit
have taken up one step further and said
you don't need a permit at all you can
just carry whatever you want ten states
now allow individuals to carry concealed
weapons in public without a permit
across the country the number of
concealed carry weapon holders has
skyrocketed from under five million in
2007 to more than 13 million today
despite the surge Americans remain
divided on the issue a recent Gallup
poll shows a small minority favored
concealed carry provided background
checks and proper training are in place
the industry has been very attentive to
opportunities to you know cultivate a
sense of fear John Donoghue studies the
connection between concealed carry
permits and crime I think many of the
people who purchase guns think that this
is going to make them feel safer I
suspect a certain number of them feel a
lot more apprehensive you're constantly
feeling the need to be alert
now this the center of my world ads like
this one for Daniel defense to pick the
world as an increasingly dangerous place
where being armed is the only way to
stay safe
Daniel defence defending your nation
defending your home the NRA is
constantly trying to use episodes of
terrorism or mass shootings to encourage
more sales of guns anytime there is an
upward tick in crime they make it seem
like the Wild West has returned to the
Urban Katee two years of this place you
have a 12-gauge the concealed carry
market brings in hundreds of millions of
dollars for the gun industry every year
even California known for its tough gun
laws has seen a push in some parts of
the state to make obtaining a permit
nearly as easy as getting a driver's
license I have opened up CCW permit
County for the first time in several
sheriff since taking office seven years
ago the sheriff of Sacramento County
Scott Jones has handed out thousands of
concealed carry permits it's one of the
largest increases in the country but
many are concerns that rapidly
increasing the number of concealed carry
permits will lead to more violence Keon
blitz is an Army veteran we all want you
talking about you know the number of
concealed carry permits under Scott
Jones how many of those concealed carry
permits were issued to gun holders of
color vast majority I'm understanding
his predominantly white I don't feel
safe carrying it got around think about
who gets the most scrutiny for carrying
around guns and pump personnel if I were
to walk around with a gun holster on my
hip the odds are I'm probably going to
get stopped sarasu
awfully funny tall doctor Express all to
get a dad out sometimes police panic
when they see a gun that's what happened
in Minnesota last year when police
pulled over falando castillo who had a
concealed carry permit we got pulled
over for a busted taillight in the back
he they killed my boyfriend he's
licensed he's carried so he's licensed
to carry he had a firearm and he was
reaching for his wallet and the officer
just shot him in his earned hold on CCW
holders have also snapped during
confrontations this police body cam
footage captured what happened when
Steven Jones a student at Northern
Arizona University got into a fight and
ended up shooting four people because
our look will become I need Guardian
here immediately okay
I don't know serve it I know that some
people were transported to the hospital
okay
we're just going to put them on softer
this way it's like people put your put
your hands the other with this you know
that I know we've seen a whole series of
bad things happening when people carry
guns from shooting themselves having
their kids shoot them to getting
involved in disputes with others where
somebody gets killed that otherwise
wouldn't be killed to better understand
why issuing concealed carry permits is
rapidly on the rise I went to speak with
the man at the center of the controversy
sheriff Jones at Sacramento County in my
office to protect the citizens of
Sacramento County I mean I my before I
lay my head down at night I have to make
sure 101.5 million people are safe
sheriff Jones says that when he took
office in 2010 the recession led to him
losing almost a third of his force and
he began to worry about public safety
so you're thinking arm the citizens we
couldn't be everywhere and so I wanted
to empower folks not only did it comport
to my own personal view but I wanted to
make sure that I was empowering folks to
be able to protect themselves and their
families when we couldn't be there at
the right times to do it for them Jones
says his office approves 90% of
applications for concealed carry permits
typically only those who have criminal
records or have previously been
committed to a mental health facility
are denied before being issued a permit
applicants must take a class often
taught with several dozen other students
I started out the business trying to do
groups like that and I felt like I was
not able to give the student anything
there was no instruction the
rubber-stamp
to rubber-stamp yeah I don't do
rubber-stamped veteran instructor guy
oxr teaches students one at a time
something he feels is essential for
learning how to carry a concealed gun
responsibly so you've learned a lot
smells good huh
Michaela's sterling is a volunteer
firefighter and a new CCW permit holder
she's one of a growing number of
Americans who feel that carrying a gun
is the best way to stay safe if you
don't have any sort of training you kind
of just pull your gun out and shoot at
someone who is looking at you and it
turns into kind of bad situation whereas
if you have training you kind of know
okay this is what I was taught how can I
not use my life and as possible dinner's
ready go pop pop most courses that I've
done before don't actually have a
picture of a real person well guess what
if you carry a gun for self-defense
that's what you'll be shooting a real
person know a black silhouette now now
you're going to actually be shooting a
person and if you have to defend your
life or someone else's life you need to
understand that what's going to be like
person for several years sheriff Jones
claimed his CCW program with an
unqualified success and he could hardly
keep up with demand in public statements
he claimed there had been no violent
acts committed by any CCW holders to
whom he'd issued permits and I can worry
about able to show a willingness to go
through the legal indicates to required
to carry weapon not worry about
I'm not worried there is not been able
in the history of Seconal County
good job by older who concealed weapons
permit issued by this off
however when Ben pepper was shot that
Halloween night in San Francisco the
shooter Honshu se Lee had been issued a
CCW permit by Jones's office in
Sacramento allowing him to carry his
Glock 45 almost anywhere in the state of
California Jones said he failed to learn
about the shooting of Ben pizza because
of a clerical error
you have a system of human beings you
have human beings that have the CCW
you have human beings and us that are
using our best judgment to issue them so
there could be spectacular failures you
can't just take an isolated incident and
say well the programs a failure because
someone got killed it's a bit of science
it's a bit of art right so it's a it's
trying to marry up science and on if
you're not on top of something that was
that dramatic and created national news
you're probably not attentive enough to
your job to really merit being there
although the near fatal shooting of
pestilence is the only shooting by a CCW
holder here it's far from the only crime
public records show that the sheriff has
had to revoke more than 200 CCWs
for crimes and negative interactions
with law enforcement let's say those 200
should never been issued okay there's
still 7800 that I did issue that nothing
bad has happened that are empowered for
their own safety and you can advocate
and opine for whatever position you hold
but I have an additional burden that you
don't have I have an additional burden
of keeping a million and a half people
safe
well CCW for me has a piece in that
discussion in that equation
[Music]
how do you feel about the fact that
there are 8,000 new concealed carry
permits were handed out in Sacramento
that's putting the public safety at risk
on very troubled by that in 2001
Amanda Wilcox his daughter Laura then a
19 year old college student was shot and
killed at the mental health clinic where
she was working in this small Northern
California town this is exactly the kind
of place where you would think that you
would have worried about your daughter
being randomly shocked by somebody I
wasn't worried I wasn't worried and not
if it can happen here in beautiful
Nevada City beautiful Nevada County can
happen everywhere and it does today
Wilcox is a legislative advocate for the
California Brady Campaign to Prevent Gun
Violence she's concerned that Sheriff
Jones's permissive policies will lead to
more guns ending up in the hands of
dangerous people like the man who shot
her daughter here is this now abandoned
facility are there going to be more gun
deaths or potentially more gun deaths
when people more people are carrying
guns particularly if it's untrained
people with very low standards like in
other states yeah then more people are
going to go through what I went through
over the past decade Wilcox has helped
pass dozens of gun control laws in
California I cannot get my daughter back
and I miss her every single day we need
a way to disarm dangerous people and I
ask you all to figure it out because
people are dying in our state this is
not an easy recovery no no I'm still
recovering you know like if you I tell
people today like I'll never view the
same effort ever I'll never be the same
because like I was living this life that
like I just didn't I thought I was gonna
live forever
you also got shot in the head and you're
now here standing talking about it yeah
I know it's real do you think about the
guy who shot you much like I lost I won
you know I'm live
gun control advocates look at pestis
case as a reason to limit concealed
carry
president Trump however has vowed to
take the concept of concealed carry a
step further
forcing states to accept all concealed
gun permits no matter where they were
issued it's possible that the position
that the sheriff is vacant in Sacramento
will be the constitutional rule for the
entire country our full documentary
series about guns in America covers
other controversial issues such as smart
gun technology the influence of the NRA
in politics and the popularity of the
ar-15 make sure to check out our series
and subscribe to aj+
for more docs